only evening gets long about this time
and there's a five anxious nominees out
there so I'm gonna kind of cut to the
chase
I'll have the names of the presenters
right and I just want to get
teleprompter on me I was going to do
this I was going to do this without the
teleprompter - okay the nominees for
director this year are Jim Sheridan in
the name of the Father
[Music]
Jane Campion for the pen
James ivory for the remains of the day
Steven Spielberg for Schindler's List
and Robert Altman for shortcuts
[Music]
so we won't go far here the Oscar goes
to this is a big surprise Steven
Spielberg
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how I actually uh I have friends who
have won this before but and I swear I
have never held one before this is the
first time I've ever had one of these in
my aunt oh dear let me just start by
saying that this never could have
happened this never could have gotten
started without a survivor named poldek
pfefferberg who Oskar Schindler saved
from Auschwitz from Belsen he's the man
he's the man who talked Thomas Keneally
into writing the book I owe him such a
debt all of us owe him such a debt he
has carried the story of Oskar Schindler
to all of us a complete a man of
complete obscurity who makes us wish and
hope for Oskar Schindler's in all of our
lives I have to thank
I want to thank Sid Sheinberg for giving
me the book Thank You SID I want to I
want to thank Steve Zaillian for a
screenplay of inordinate restraint
I have great actors in this movie Liam
Thank You Rafe thank you Ben Kingsley
thank you I want to thank my wife who's
here with me tonight for rescuing me 92
days in a row in Krakow Poland last
winter when things got just too
unbearable and my mom who's here who is
my lucky charm whom I love very very
much
and and to the six million who who can't
be watching this among the 1 billion
watching this telecast tonight thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]